ont profité de la pandémie
pour faire le grand saut
et déménager leur atelier
à Frelighsburg, dans
les Cantons-de-l'Est.
Marie-Claude Morin
les a rencontrés.
- Depuis la mi-mai,
les clients de Fumile achètent
leurs chapeaux à Frelighsburg.
Le couple de chapeliers
a passé trois ans à Montréal,
en plein centre-ville.
ALEX SURPRENANT
copropriétaire, Fumile
- L'année passée, on s'est dit
que vu qu'on se voyait à long
terme, aller en région, bien là,
pourquoi pas attaquer tout de
suite à court terme en région?
- Pendant cinq mois, les deux
entrepreneurs ont complètement
transformé un ancien resto-bar.
MÉLODIE LAVERGNE
copropriétaire, Fumile
- C'est un peu fou, à quelque
part, de s'en aller de la ville,
mais déjà, je trouve que,
de un, on est moins perdus dans
la masse puis il y a tellement
de gens passionnés en région.
- Ils ont aussi installé
un coin buvette avec
deux terrasses.
- Tu viens, tu es pas pressé,
tu prends le temps de prendre
soit un café, soit un verre,
tu prends le temps de t'asseoir,
prendre le temps de bien
choisir son chapeau. Puis,
on veut que ce soit un tout.
- L'objectif : que les clients
visitent la boutique
au moins une fois...
- Je vais prendre
ton moule de tête.
- ... pour avoir
leurs mesures exactes.
- Et bien coller
sur ta tête.
- Après, ceux qui le veulent
peuvent commander en ligne
les chapeaux qui se vendent
entre 200 et 1000 $.
- Notre clientèle
qu'on a développée à Montréal
pendant trois ans, c'est pas
qu'est-ce qu'on s'attendait.
C'est même pas, des fois,
du monde de Montréal, en fait.
Puis, c'est Monsieur et Madame
Tout-le-monde qui apprécient
les belles choses, qui veulent
se payer de la qualité.
Ça, tu en as partout,
de ces gens-là, ils sont
pas juste en ville.
- Mets-tu un ruban sur le brim?
- Oui, je vais le mettre noir."
- Le déménagement a permis
d'agrandir la boutique,
mais aussi l'atelier,
ce qui offre la possibilité
d'augmenter la production.
- Oui, on est des artistes,
mais aussi des entrepreneurs,
donc on veut que ça fonctionne.
Puis si on veut que
ça fonctionne, il faut offrir
des prix compétitifs. Mais pour
ça, il faut faire de la chaîne
aussi, il faut être capables
de produire plus en masse.
Mais pour ça, on avait besoin
d'espace pour les machines,
mais aussi pour s'installer
comme il faut.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les propriétaires de Fumile
comptent d'ailleurs approcher
de petites chaînes de magasins
et des boutiques indépendantes
pour vendre des collections
plus abordables.
- Oh! yes, right on!
- Ici Marie-Claude Morin,
Radio-Canada, Frelighsburg.
- Il y a un miroir juste là,
si tu veux te regarder.
♪